hey Vsauce Michael here not knowing what
to do with your hands or offering a
handshake when the other person offers a
fist bump for getting someone's name not
having anything to say and forgetting
your phone at home so you can't be
distracted by it getting caught staring
at a stranger striking up a conversation
with someone you don't know in a
bathroom someone over sharing telling a
group too much information overhearing a
couple breaking up noticing food in
someone's teeth but not telling them and
well now it's been too long and bringing
it up would be weird
smelly now you fart in an elevator that
wasn't yours but well now you can't even
react to it or mention that you've
noticed it or pretend you even know what
a fart is all of those things are
awkward we don't like awkwardness it
makes us uncomfortable cringe but what
is awkwardness why is it good and who is
the main character of the universe
to really understand awkwardness we need
to put it in context with the entire
family of forces that guide social
behavior think of this sheet of
cardboard as a list of all possible
behaviors it's not infinite because of
the limits of science and biology
you can't move faster than light or be
in two places at once
you can't wear pants made out of molten
lead next there are legal limits the
laws of the state they delineate what
you agreed not to do lest the
authorities punish murder
stealing speeding what's left is molded
by the finer tool of social expectations
it's not illegal to chew with your mouth
open or not cover a sneeze on a crowded
bus or act disrespectfully but it is
frowned upon punished not by the police
but by social ostracism public of
probiem being called rude gross mean
annoying awkwardness is the finest tool
it sans social dynamics by smoothing out
what even etiquette doesn't rule on it's
not a violation of the laws of physics
to accidentally hug someone for longer
than they expected it's not against the
law either and the etiquette for how
long a hug should last is it black and
white what it is awkward like touching a
hot stove or getting a parking fine or
losing friends awkwardness nudges us to
avoid certain actions in the future and
smooth things out when they happen
people who demonstrate
self-consciousness when needed are
communicating cooperative intentions
which helps them get along well with
others it's no coincidence that brains
susceptible to feeling occasional
awkwardness would become so common
they're successful at cooperating at
social life
feeling awkward shows that you
understand and are keen on smooth social
exchanges now too much or too little
concern for social rules isn't healthy
but research is found that just the
right amount is great when a person
shows remorse or embarrassment or
awkward discomfort when appropriate
others perceive them as being more
trustworthy and their actions as more
forgivable and it's not just perception
such individuals also tend to be more
objectively pro-social when tested
kinder more generous even when a person
is completely oblivious to a faux pas
they've committed awkwardness still
arises people around them can feel
uncomfortable it's called vicarious
embarrassment and it's a function of
empathy the ability to feel what others
feel or will feel when or if they
realize what they've just done the more
EEE someone is that is easily and
pathetically embarrassed the harder it
is for them to sit through other
people's cringe inducing moments even
fictional ones like in cringe comedy
research is found that being more easily
and pathetically embarrassed does not
correlate to being more easily
embarrassed yourself instead it's linked
to being more empathetic an important
capacity for social creatures to have
our seemingly counterintuitive
attraction to viewing cringy moments
like say bad American Idol auditions is
perhaps then just a light form of morbid
curiosity you may think that awkwardness
is totally different from physical pain
or outright name-calling but your brain
would disagree
you see research has found that social
missteps activate among other regions
the secondary somatosensory cortex and
dorsal posterior insula areas of the
brain that are also connected to the
sensation of physical pain our brains
process the breaking of social standards
and the breaking of bones through
similar neural pathways likewise the
same sympathetic nervous system that
mobilizes you to deal with physical
threats fight-or-flight is activated by
social challenges where awkwardness or
embarrassment might be at stake like
events where you are very aware of being
watched speaking in front of a group or
embarrassing yourself in front of on
workers or having nothing to say on a
first date
awkward silence your blood pressure
increases causing you to overheat and
sweat oxygen is needed for fighting and
running so breathing increases and
digestion shuts down causing nausea and
butterflies in your stomach your body
instinctively contracts into a
protective fetal position and fighting
that reaction to act natural
makes you shake blood vessels and your
extremities contract to prioritize major
organs leaving you with cold fingers and
toes and nose these symptoms don't
alleviate awkwardness they compound it
but that's history's fault long before
human social dynamics were complicated
enough to involve you is it one kiss or
two or politics at Thanksgiving dinner
we developed primitive reactions to
physical threats and haven't had enough
time yet to evolve newer ones
self-conscious anxiety can be tough to
get out of our minds after we've done
something awkward fixating on social
blunders is easy and hard to overcome
why was I so unsure so unconfident
so awkward well some of the blame may
lie with the neurotransmitter oxytocin
oxytocin is sometimes called the love
hormone because it modulates pro-social
feelings like trust
attachment which it does in fact nasal
sprays of oxytocin are being used to
increased trust during couples therapy
and in the reduction of anxiety and
depression though there are fears that
it could also be used to deviously
increase trust and make a person more
susceptible to con artists schemes but
oxytocin also modulates negative social
feelings like fear and anxiety a dose of
it makes people better at recognizing
the facial expressions for disgust and
fright it's also involved in the
feelings that make us approach or avoid
certain social stimuli and it may play a
role in making positive and negative
social interactions more salient in our
memories that is stand out more command
more of our attention after the fact
make us think about them more negative
ones especially because of what
psychologists call negativity bias all
things being equal negative social
interactions and negative emotions have
a greater impact on our mental states
than positive ones in fact we have more
words for negative emotions than
positive ones and a richer vocabulary to
describe them thus such memories and
thoughts can be tough to just get over
what does the other person think of me I
was so awkward are they telling other
people we replay social encounters in
our heads over and over again surely the
person we were awkward with remembers us
the same way we're remembering ourselves
and is equally fixated on that awkward
thing we did or are they a great wet
blanket for smothering the fire of
self-conscious anxieties is perspective
consider the famous advice of Eleanor
Roosevelt you wouldn't worry so much
about what others think of you if you
realized how seldom they
do as much as you obsess over yourself
you're not the first thing on everyone
else's minds they're worried about
themselves what you think about them and
more importantly what they think about
themselves you're not the center of
their world another famous old piece of
advice tells us that in your 20s and 30s
you worry about what other people think
about you in your 40s and 50s you stop
worrying what other people think about
you and then finally in your 60s and 70s
you realize that they were never
thinking about you in the first place
the tendency to act and think as though
you are the true main character of the
universe has been called protagonist
disease it seeps into our behavior all
the time for instance the fundamental
attribution error when evaluating
actions you often view yourself as a
complex character acted upon by various
challenges and antagonists whereas other
people are seen as just one-dimensional
background characters with simple
unchanging roles the guy who took way
too long
ordering in front of you this morning
well he's obviously just an innately
annoying person that's his entire
purpose but when you take too long
ordering well it's because the staff was
unhelpful or you were flustered and
preoccupied by an earlier conversation
you are the main character after all you
know a lot more about what's going on in
your life it's easy to live like that
there isn't time or mental space to
consider every other person as
complicated and fully fleshed out
but they are the realization of this has
a name a name given to it by the
dictionary of obscure sorrows one of my
favorite resources and now YouTube
channels they rap profound concepts up
in tiny little word packages to be sure
giving something a name doesn't show
that you know it or how to feel about it
but nonetheless words put handles on
things so we can manipulate them hold
them down offer them to others feel
bigger than the concepts they label now
their word for acknowledging that you
are just in extra in other people's
stories not even cast in most of them is
sonder this is their definition of it
saunder the realization that each random
passerby is living a life as vivid and
complex as your own populated with their
own ambitions friends routines worries
and inherited craziness an epic story
that continues invisibly around you like
an anthill sprawling deep underground
with elaborate passageways to thousands
of other lives that you'll never know
existed in which you might only appear
once as an extra sipping coffee in the
background as a blur of traffic passing
on the highway as a lighted window at
dusk acknowledging this makes your
awkwardness look small but it also makes
all of you look small tiny a needle in a
giant haystack but nonetheless in
possession of a big idea
your blemishes are lost from far away
and so is your uniqueness but the view
from way up here
well it's unbeatable and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]